i know you both read a lot of scripts or
get sent a lot of scripts uh and i'm so
curious what was it about this one that
said i really want to do this
um
i think on the surface what's what's uh
on the surface clearly this is an action
thriller on the surface this can be read
as kind of a trite thriller in the vein
of something we've seen a lot of but
really what attracted me uh
in it was this image that was at the end
of the film originally which was james
harper waiting out into this murky water
with his oil refinery straight ahead of
in some central american country and a
coke can washes past them in the dirty
water and that to me
said everything about what
um
this writer wanted to communicate about
what he was talking about really what
this is a
character study of a man who was raised
on fictions these stories and he was
raised on particular stories democracy
freedom
honor
courage brotherhood
america the shining city on the hill
and in the matter of a couple hours all
of that is taken away from him
he's kicked out the stories are ripped
from his spine so to speak and he then
has to recreate himself using other
fictions and that came around a time i
was reading
sapiens by yuval harari and i was taken
really with this idea that humans are
the only animal the only species
who tell themselves stories to give them
purpose and a reason to live no other
species on the planet so far as we know
does that i found that really
interesting uh ben what was it for you
it's it's continuing the uh
the story of the returning soldier
is is so rich because it's
it's
it's so complex
and we
chris
we're we're the desert war generation
we grew up with this
uh afghanistan
we haven't even begun to see the mental
health issues that
20 years in the desert there uh and how
they'll affect our men and women who
have served
over the years i've gotten to know a lot
of people who
who have served in those wars
and they've shared their struggles
and unseen scars with me
and
i think
if we can use a film to ask how are we
taking care of the people that we've
trained to kill in the name of
protecting our our nation um what do we
do with them when they get home and so
many of them feel at least my friends
have talked about feeling uh abandoned
so when one feels abandoned one tries to
create a new home and quite often it's
put your skill set to use which is going
to private security
there's money
there's camaraderie
uh there's there's purpose and point
but it's murky waters and it's dangerous
waters because there's no government
looking after you
in that theater of war so i think those
questions are are always going to be uh
compelling films to tell
one of the things i also really enjoyed
about this film is that none of the
characters are over the top everyone
felt very grounded and realistic in
terms of you know you didn't have some
maniacal per do you know what i mean
yeah that was the whole i think the
whole idea about it is that this is the
anti-board this is real people that
these people do this kind of stuff
obviously some of the action is
uh i don't think there's gonna be a fire
fight god willing you know uh
in the middle of the city center
although that certainly has happened
before but
um
it was very very important that this is
there's a joe everyman quality to this
is that this is
james harper is the soldier you know
and um
uh
this is about being accessible
and it's really about having a film and
thank god uh
the financiers and everybody was behind
it of you know there's 30 minutes of
a human being just being a human being
who happens to be a soldier with his
family
and there's 30 minutes of
there's no action
this could be a family drama
and
to set that up to throw that person that
you come to know that's taking their kid
out to teach them how to swim and lives
in a clapboard house
trying to pay the bills and
loves his wife and then also does some
pretty
crazy
heinous violence um
those two things can live side by side i
agree i gotta wrap i'm just gonna say
congrats and like i said um please make
more movies together have a fantastic
day
you